sorry his council booked back because
his videos
just give him a couple of minutes
as you can see
right okay can i now ask if um
gnp can uh the representative give their
presentation and speak to the daily
evidence
that we've seen yes thanks committee
this is an application simulator to the
premises known as astoria as you know
where the premises license holder was
sure leisure holding limited they've
been sold since i understand the 22nd of
march 2019.
i understand the dps is now miss davis
um so gmp have concerns in relation to
the premises
and the upholding of the license and
objectives happening of crime and
disorder public safety
also public nuisance uh protection of
children of palmers are really featuring
heavily in this application it's the
other three that's uh that's a feature
more there have been a significant
number of incidents which have occurred
on the premises
that can be seen from the cctv footage
which you've already obviously had our
sites off and has been produced and
viewed by a sales committee
all parts of the applicants have also
seen it regardless of the incidents
that have occurred at the premises and
their description
that's contained in the bundle at pages
55-60
in total there's mention of 17 incidents
not all of them are violence and
disorder uh some of them are other
incidents but the majority are violence
and disorder
you'll notice
from the cctv footage highlighted that
there are some concerns
with the premises
those concerns being in control
and management
with regards to the door team just the
general management overall
from where the premises are situated
unfortunately for them situated directly
outside a crossing
people are constantly spilling down into
the street
onto the crossing when you've seen the
incidence of disorder they've pushed out
from the premises into the middle of the
road
cars have had to stop
there's been
bedlam disorder no control
and because of that there's a real
concern for patrons that visit those
premises and also general members of the
public who may be walking past
at times as well
you'll note with regards to the
incidents in question
in the bundle
that there are concerns
with a number of the incidents with
regards to
incident four which was that there was a
male in a white shirt who actually hit
somebody
um
after hitting them he then went back to
the door
and um stood outside the premises and
continued drinking his drink he wasn't
challenged in any way
and there was no concerns raised with
regards to his behavior he was he
assumes it was about a large gentleman
well-built
with regards to the incident obviously
causes concern but again it's the
general
feel of the premises and the general
manner which is being dealt with
if you also consider the incident which
spilled out of the premises
um sorry can you say yeah
we spilled out the premises
on the
incident five which was sunday the 12th
of september at half past midnight
you couldn't really see the door team
outside when the fight started
nobody controlled the crowd which was
outside the premises
it then escalated they started to walk
across the road and fight across the
road then the door stuff appeared
and started to become involved
you could see it was the doorstep from
astoria and also at that time they had
the badges on and they had their
identity
they walked over it probably zero zero
thirty hours then walked away zero
thirty two hours then they came back
over at zero 33 hours
this incident went on for a considerable
amount of time and there was no control
the time to control the incident would
have been when it occurred directly
outside the premises
but they had no control of that time and
that was really getting released to the
door staff and the daughter there at the
time they weren't they were sufficient
they weren't properly prepared and
because of that they weren't able to
show them when it did escalate
so there is a real concern in regards to
the incidents but the management and
also the the door team in question
so we do have that
um serious concern regards those
premises
we have had the
i'm not going to go into the bundle in
any significant detail committee because
obviously you've seen the bundle you've
been able to read the bundle i think
it's more observations i'm going to be
providing a pc packer will provide with
regards to that bundle of evidence we
have received the information from
astoria which was a five-page document
it is notable and i'm sure they can
advise us to while this has occurred
we've had no contact at all from astoria
the first concept we had was yesterday
at 4pm when we received an email
containing a five page document
within our phase five page document it
goes through the
conditions or some of the conditions
which we have
suggested will be appropriate
and it also makes certain observations
with regards to
those
conditions which we require
and also
observations in relation to discussions
between pc packet and the premises in
question
with regards to those premises
discussions with pc packer it is
suggested that there
have been meetings that pc pack hasn't
attended and not turned up on various
occasions that's vehemently denied
um with regards to the five-page
document which we'll go through
shortly
there is
no policies
attached to those documents there is no
dispersal policy
no policy with regards to the door team
no policy with regards to the manner in
which individuals who work at the
premises are going to be trained with
regards to the lack of objectives and
are they going to serve individuals
and there's no information or detail
with regards to how those premises are
going to be managed
is basically an agreement to a number of
the conditions which we've put forward
and objections to others
with no reasoning behind those
objections and no detailed reasoning and
no evidence to support those contentions
as well
so i'll just uh
introduce a pc packer to um for some
observations as well so pc packet
can you just um
explain to the committee the meetings
and discussions you've had with the
premises in question
absolutely sir
and so as i've said in the bundle only
my statement prior to the premises
opening i made several contacts with the
license holder to try and establish how
the premises would operate what type of
apprentices it was intended to be and to
give him the information
from a previous
experience as to how that premises was
managed
i've tried on several occasions for him
to put variations in to meet the license
and objectives in order to turn the
premises around and on one particular
occasion himself and the dps were
invited into stratford police station
and it was around just after the
christmas time or around the christmas
time because of serious disorder where
he verbally agreed that
he would look at putting a variation in
and he would meet the conditions that i
was asking him to consider and it never
happened
in relation to what
uh my sort of source says i totally
dispute the fact that in the bundle he
says that uh i've cancelled meetings
that's not happened it'll show from the
bundles i've presented that i've had
regular contacts over the last couple of
years
the main concern is the disorder the
disorder disorder outside and also
disorder inside there appears to be
absolutely no control whatsoever
um and although i totally agree that um
the licensing is courteous and we have a
civil conversation it doesn't appear to
want to put anything forward in terms of
changing the premises to make it better
and to make it fit for purpose i'm not
quite sure and so what that premises is
it's described as about it's described
as a restaurant but it operates as an
actual bit weekends
and
so the conditions that we've put in my
bundle reflect it's a weekend
the operating of a nightclub because the
final video that you were shown from the
rear of the premises gives you an
insight as to how the premises operate
inside people are up dancing the
drinking and it's it resembles that of a
nightclub which is why those conditions
are in there
thank you
thanks bc plucker um
now just to go uh further a committee in
relation to the document which we
received
from astoria uh premises and
the discussions with regards to certain
conditions
the first condition that has been
highlighted is we've requested
the approved contractor scheme status
for the door company which should be
employed at the premises and we've also
asked for six security doors that
daughter a sixth security staff door
team as well
in relation to the approved contract to
status door scheme
um you may be aware of this committee
i'm sure you are aware some degree has
been implemented in areas of truffle i'm
quite sure but it is more than a budget
quality
it provides a
thorough professional service by certain
companies
who are do have a
[Music]
you may call it budget quality status
it's a it's an enhanced status
it's highly valued by such companies
and because of that you guarantee you're
going to get a certain level of quality
with regards to the manner in which
they're going to manage doors and
they're going to deal with premises in
question they don't call corners and
they make sure that everything is done
is to a high standard
approved contractor status companies
work throughout the greater manchester
area
and they do especially work between city
centre establishments where there have
been concerns with premises in the past
and it is recommended by the security
industry authority and also by our by
ourselves by greater manchester police
that such companies are employed uh
where required with regards to the door
company that has been employed
at the premises and the door team have
been in place they've been ineffective
and haven't delivered the services
required if we look at the incident
where which we saw went inside the
premises
at no point
can anybody see be seen with their
identification of the sia door team
there's no idea we don't know who the
door team are and who actually if any of
them were security staff on the night in
question it was complete bedlam and
that's very much the case
across those incidents which have been
seen and across incidents which take
place there's just no control there
it's just a lack of control
and that will be improved if there's an
approved contract status term employed
with regards to the number of door staff
that are required i'll again turn to pc
packet and just ask you to address you
on those issues so piece of packages
explain to the committee please yes
sir and attending there on several
occasions when there have been reports
of incidents and
there's clearly not enough on the dog to
be able to control those coming in and
those leaving
so
my
idea behind asking for six is that at a
weekend the two come on at seven o'clock
to prevent those from coming into a late
night venue to stop prior to that
another two at nine o'clock to assist
those that are there from seven o'clock
because at that point it becomes busy
and you get more customers in there and
from the video you'll see that they do
need more support two isn't enough
they're outnumbered
inside the premises we have a fire exit
door at the back that fire exit door i
believe cannot be locked and has been
used in the past
as an exit point so my request is to
have a member door staff at the back to
manage that exit door to prevent it
being used as a an egress and ingress
and then an additional door staff to
have control of the actual floor inside
the premises
so committee it's been suggested
that they're prepared to employ
three-door staff on friday
and four on saturday nights and then
they're proud to bank holiday christmas
eve you'll know to point six of their
submissions
with regards to the
incidents which have taken place where
why were requesting uh the door staff on
certain nights is friday night into
saturday night
they were incidents
three eight ten eleven thirteen sixteen
or seventeen
now they were in the early hours that's
at pages 55 56
57 58 59 and 60 of the bundle and then
saturday night into sunday
they were incidents 2 4
5 12 and 15 and again
they were quite serious incidents and if
the sufficient numbers would have been
in place at those times
it could have been dealt with
accordingly but they just didn't have
the numbers in place that's where that's
what the issue was hence why i was
suggesting there should be six
with regards to the risk assessments
um i think that's agreed
and we accept this as well they're
willing to undertake risk assessments
and employ additional door staff if so
required i think in relation to that
risk assessment criteria then we'll have
to be
more detailed with regards to when the
risk assessments provided usually 28
days before with regards to any risk
assessment unless it was agreed by the
police with regards to the dps there is
a new dps in place now
and uh i believe the
police have accepted that dps there's no
concerns there with regards to the dress
code
and it has been agreed that the
amendment and there'll be no caps or
hoodies
to be worn
but again
we've not seen the policy
but it's going to be in place so we
can't comment further all we can say is
that it appears it will be agreed but we
don't know what that agreement is it's
not in any detail
um the rear door
is currently used as a fire door
and this thing is part of a revised
security strategy mr sure is aiming to
create a fenced smoking area to the rear
of the building to become active at 9pm
you saw the last incident
that was the
that was that was the after after event
that was on the um 20 26th of december
where you'll see the body cam footage
and officers were outstanding the wall
through the back of the premises
if you look at the outside area at the
back there's double yellow lines
on the side
that's not an area where you could have
a fenced off smoking area
it's an area where deliveries are made
you can see next to where it was there
was bins in place it's where the back of
the premises are there's no control
there and i would suggest it can't be
used for that type of area but obviously
that's a matter for yourselves
committing like i said you're not that's
probably and obviously
my story can address you on that point
but we have concerns with regards to the
area being used for any purpose except
for the fire exit
also the requirement to remove furniture
or table and chairs from external
entrances
they have suggested
being removed after 9 pm
that's open to conjecture and i'll put a
discussion really with your sales
committee it's a matter where at this
present time if you look at the
incidents which have occurred
and you look at the general
control of the premises on the front
it'd be suggested that they shouldn't be
allowed
any table or she has outside
and any movement outside those premises
should be
discouraged because
of where the premises are situated and
the general manner in which in which the
patrons are conducting themselves and
there's no control outside those
crevices in this present time
so it's how they're going to
improve that control
now obviously part of that control is
going to be the dispersal policy we've
not seen the dispersal policy we don't
know what's going to be in the dispersal
policy and how it's going to work so
again it's open and then we can't really
mention any further regards to that
point by making any further comments
also with regards to the proposed
condition i think it said preventing
drinking
proposing this to prevent drinking in
external areas is not accepted
so mr jorah's statement
he intends to redevelop the roof space
of the premises into a roof terrace
and that the prohibition on drinking
outside would make this unworkable
at this present time
there is no roof terrace
and
that's something that mr shaw's going to
have to work on
so at this present time we suggest there
should be no drinking area externally
outside those premises you'll see
from a number of incidents that there's
no control when individuals are walking
out of those premises with regards to
having drinking receptacles somebody was
seen during one of the fights to walk
across the road with a full part of full
pipe beer and walk back somebody also
walks across with
a prosecco glass or champagne whatever
it may be was across the road and left
the premises without being challenged
whatsoever they were glass receptacles
so again it's a further concern and if
it is the case that he's going to create
a roof terrace then that's something
that could be varied on the licensing
conditions and due course once that's in
place
and it could be dealt with accordingly
i'm sure if it's dealt with
appropriately it would be agreed between
the authorities and the story
with regards to the proposed condition
prohibiting vertical drinking
that suggested by greater manchester
police was in relation to the premises
in question at this present time
obviously if astoria
can provide assurances to yourselves
committee that they can manage these
premises effectively
and have a suitable model where
individuals aren't spilling out onto the
street and fighting and also blocking
the pathway
with the crusting outside it may be a
case of it can be a vertical drinking
establishment but in the daytime it
appears not to be the case it's that
type of establishment at night and
we think they should maybe reconsider
their business model as to how they're
going to deal with such matters
regards to the personal license holder
being present on weekends the reason
we've requested such a
condition is because as you can see from
the premises it's complete disorganized
chaos
and these are all conditions in place to
try and resolve those issues
now obviously
if the premises can offer
an assurance to your sales committee and
the necessary policies to deal with
those mischiefs that are being created
you may think that's not required may
not be appropriate
but
at this present time as i've said we've
not seen any policies
or any discussions how they're going to
deal with those aspects
we've also mentioned the terminal hour
being removed from 1 30 weekends to 12
30.
the reason again for that is that
obviously the more individuals drink
the more concerns there are with regards
to the behavior which seems to be
evident in those incidents which have
occurred
and with the gas levels incident on the
cctv you'll know those the majority of
those incidents for half past 12 have
possible
the search policy we've been advised
that the provisions the proposed
conditions can be agreed we'd need to
see the search policy we still haven't
seen that
with regards to the cctv
we're advising the conditions agreed in
full
so obviously there's no dispute regards
to that aspect part of that condition is
that we
require a
cctv monitor or a monitor tv monitor
near the front of the premises that
individuals that are visiting those
premises are aware that they are being
filmed and that's usually an extremely
good deterrent as well with regards to
controlling people's behavior if they're
aware they're filmed and recorded
regards to the notices they've been
agreed as well so they're not concerned
there
with regards to the
the drugs uh policy and the concerns we
have
there seems to be some concern with
regards to capturing any drug capture on
cctv mentions made within that
that
individuals may be in the toilets
with drugs and then taken into different
premises to be
a film on the cctv may call cause
causing altercation
fighting and disorder well that
shouldn't be causing that issue because
those individuals should be being
searched when they're entering the
premises if they're in the toilets and
they're doing the drugs it's too late
that's not the point the policy the
policy is to carry out our searches to
put those measures in place when you're
coming into the premises and if they do
that
it will stop any concerns with regards
to drugs
being in the premises in the first place
so it's just a probably a difference of
opinion with regards to how that works
but it's found to be extremely effective
premises and it also protects the
premises and it protects the individuals
in question as well and the door teams
there's also mentioned that mr shaw has
in the past notified the police of drug
captures
but anyone's yet to attend premises we
have no evidence to that effect we've
not provided if it would have had the
evidence would have divided it obviously
we've not had anything mr short either
so that they can address that point with
you
and with regards to the over 21 policy
to be honest
it probably as you can see from the
incidents which have occurred
it's probably not appropriate for under
21. probably to be more appropriate than
over 25 policy with regards to the
individuals involved but
we're not seeking that we're just
seeking assurances with regards to
the manner in which
they deal with individuals and um
etc
i think committee that probably covers
most areas the only other area which is
um mentioned is regards to the suggested
route for body-worn cameras
for the
door teams this seems to mention within
there
and again it seems to be um maybe some
confusion between
uh ourselves and the story and everybody
with regards to systems failing and
maintaining stop keeping everything that
would be a matter for astoria greater
manchester police wouldn't be involved
in that there are a number of premises
within greater manchester and in the
city centres who undertake
to have body-worn video cameras
and it's quite popular
um
popular things to take up due to the
fact that it provides protection to the
door teams and provides protection to
members of the public again and it gives
us assurances and gives across a
professional feel to the whole setup and
again that may come back to the approved
contractor status in regards to getting
their brand professional advice in place
with regards to that
so i think excuse me
so um i believe that most issues um
committed
but
the one concern and we can obviously
discuss at the end but one concern
really is it's just at the moment we've
not seen any policies
you'll see from the cctv footage and
just from the general
um from the general bundler there seems
to be a lack of control within those
premises both inside and out and it's
how that's going to be resolved and
hence why revolve the application has
suggested that further conditions should
be applied we're not seeking to close
the premises we don't wish to put any
premises out of business
um we're not trying to make this
difficult we're just trying to make it
safe for the community and for
individuals and i believe that covers
all matters and our committee thank you
okay thank you mr kent bc packer can i
just ask just to clarify you saying that
you're not going to insist on the body
worn cameras and any of them you're
saying it's up to
astoria
it was it's a suggestion we have we
think it would be very effective and it
would assist greatly with the ghast suit
the door teams and the man in which
individuals approached the door teams
so we think it'd be effective and it'd
be useful obviously that's a matter for
your sales committee if you agree with
that proposal but we think it'd be an
effective proposal we would land a
proposal to be put forward we would like
that to be implemented but it's a matter
of yourself committee if you think
that's a step too far it can be
expensive that's understood
but it is something that can be
um a great
great value
to both patrons and all sorts of other
individuals as well there are a number
of
you'll know from the statement committed
that there are
a number of other areas which we have
discussed with regards to conditions
which haven't been addressed um by
astoria we've suggested polycarbonate
vessels and plastic bottles to be used
on a friday saturday and sunday
and also on bank holidays christmas eve
etc
that's not really been um discussed in
any any great detail but
there seems to be this suggestion that
there's been no incidents with blessings
etcetera which isn't the case there have
been incidents where pluses have been
involved
and there has been a concern with
regards to public safety because of that
and
we also have
we've discussed obviously no vertical
drinking
and also the personal license holder
and then with regards to we've also
requested a direct telephone number for
the manager of the premises and be
available all the time to the public as
premises and operation that's not really
mentioned we're not we've not seen any
mention of that aspect
also the premises i said shall ensure
that staff at the premises are trained
in respect of licensing legislation
responsible retailing
refusal of services and the challenge 25
policy
and that they're trained in their
particular roles again we've not seen a
policy for that but we'd expect a policy
and also with regards to the dispersal
policy which we've alluded to already so
we'd expect the policy in relation to
that aspect as well
okay
i believe that covers
all aspects
so
with regard to the license are you
saying that you'd like the
license to be suspended until all these
matters or the matters that are agreed
are put in place
sir we would we'd like the mass to be
suspended so everything's put in place
so it could be
repackaged
um and giving a fresh outlook the
present time
you can see the individuals that are
sending those premises
it's alluded to in in their
papers
but um they're looking at being a
high-end drinking establishment which is
why they require
rather than having polycarbonate
required lassies and required services
certain drinks etc
at the moment
with the greatest respect to
the premises as patrons the people that
are going in there don't seem to be of
high end these people going in there
with shorts hoodies caps they dressed
all over of ways and shapes and there's
no dress policy no anything um and the
people that are going in there are
fighting and causing disorder there's no
respect for the community they're
spilling out into the street they block
off the road they block off the
block off the pavement so at this moment
in time it seems peculiar regards to the
asper said yes we'd suggest that there
is a closure period
for those policies to be put in place to
retrain and to provide a lot to the
community so
and that would be what with immediate
effect are you saying or would
with immediate effects
right okay
can i just ask if uh the any other
members of the panel wish to ask any
questions
yes chair
counselor
yeah i've just got a number of questions
actually if i could uh you know you
mentioned about the uh body cams uh that
you would be approval approving of them
would that impact on some of the
conditions that you're
you've
enlisted
i mean would that would that alleviate
or would that do anything in terms of
uh affecting any of the conditions that
you know that you've that you've
mentioned
um
probably not sir you may you may have
deliberations with regards to i mean one
of the conditions that might be affected
is
with regards to the hours um i don't
know you may feel differently if there's
those measures in place in that
controlling place
um but that's the only condition i can
think which would be affected really the
rest of the conditions would um
would still be required
okay uh in terms of the uh visibility
and i noticed uh from the cctv footage
in that you couldn't tell who the as you
said rightly pointed out you know you
can't really tell who the the door staff
are uh they don't have any kind of
visibility
uh jackets or identifying
features in uh
and what business so that you could you
know from the footage if you could say
oh yeah there's there's a doorman
there's a doorman you know and in that
respect
to what extent can they engage beyond
their doorstep
you know from a legal point of view
they need to engage with if you look at
the i mean
i can address you on this because which
is a police officer but just from the
licensing perspective and the manner
office when promises to dealt with yeah
those door teams should have their
badges visibly clear with regards to who
they are and they didn't have the badges
clear they did in one of the incidents
and three of them had their badges and
they were very visible they were very it
was clear they identified who the door
team were on the other instance you
couldn't see the door scene worked there
was no doubt there didn't seem to be a
door team there and that's that's the
real crux of the matter if they have
control of that premises directly
outside the premises it shouldn't spill
out to other areas because they should
be taking the appropriate action at the
first possible opportunity and they
weren't doing that and that's why it
escalates and that's why it spills out
also with regards to the manner which
they're keeping their
the patrons around the outside
when you look at the incidents which
have occurred even before the incident
started people just walking out the
premises with drinks with everything
there's just no there's no control at
all there's no entrance there's no exit
you see inside that there seems to be an
entrance but they don't seem to be able
to control the gas who's coming in who's
going out what they're doing there's
just there's nothing there at all at the
moment that's the real issue that i
think the real feel with the the premise
at the moment
is that there's just literally no
there's no control
at all
and you pointed out you pointed out at
the back the the entry
effectively what is the fire escape is
being used as an entrance as well or an
exit uh
does it have any cctv
on that back side back end i know it was
using body cam to get that
i'm not aware of that i don't think
there is
i don't think there's any cctv currently
at the back
as far as awareness as well that is a
service yard for all the
um supermarkets that are in and around
eden square area so you get heavy trucks
coming in there
i don't know whether they come in at
night but they do come in in the day
i've driven into there in the day and
struggled to get parking spaces i don't
know in terms of legality whether
um
they would have permission to be able to
use that part of the land for the
purposes they intend to use it with it
being it the actual land i believe
belongs to and the management of eden
square
right okay and
i
just
answer that question so i've just been
told by mr shaw that there is cctv to
the rear of the premises it's been
installed by himself yeah gmp of that
site of this one
yeah
so that there is cctv to the rear of the
premises and how long has that been
there has it been
has anybody had access police had access
to that footage if they needed it well i
don't know whether the gmp have
requested it
when was it installed installed for the
room
six eight months ago i don't know if you
heard that so about approximately six to
eight months ago so the middle of uh
middle of 2021
summer of 2021.
okay and just one final point i don't
know whether that's uh for the the
police to answer the the they seem that
two uh men who were at the back there
were they the ones that happened to get
injured
the staff members the door doormen
almost i think from the papers that
showed you know was that
it was themselves okay thank you thank
you sir
thank you
yeah
that's with thomas
thank you i'll be as brief as i can um
just on on the the bundle
how often were the police called to the
um
incidents included in the bundle uh did
we attend every time and what was the
response time
i wouldn't be able to answer the
response time sir i haven't got that
information to hand in terms of
um
the call outs i've listed on the bundle
who made those calls to the police
the one in particular that was the one
where they
spilled out over the road and then we
saw it from a different angle you'll see
from the bundle on that the police
didn't attend it straight away the calls
that were coming in were that ferocious
that they held the local police back and
asked for force patrols to come in and
taser officers before they could go in
and
and deal with the situation and
i think on one or two on the bundle of
put the police didn't attend
and there might be one there might be
two in there but that's generally
because we
either get a report from cctv traffic
council cctv who then say everybody's
moved off
and there's nothing really happening now
so the police don't attend and the one
in particular on
number nine on the incidents friday the
24th of july that's one of the ones that
you saw the video where you're thinking
second to the last they all went into
the road and you'll note that um
the police were told when they arrived
that it was all quiet and nothing was
actually happening it was only when i
started looking into astoria and i went
to traffic council cctv and i viewed the
video
the the video tells a different story so
i think you know there's possibility
times where the police are getting
cancelled um or they don't turn out for
whatever reason
and their perception at that time is
there was nothing really going on what
the police don't do is then go over to
swinton to check traffic council cctv
to view what that incident was about
because they just don't have the time
i appreciate that uh also um we saw a
lot of traffic cctv and some body cam
footage um
are you able to get access to the koken
within the bundle it seems it's a
reticence
sometimes for the video to be
forthcoming from within the property are
they keeping them for the 28 days
on dvr and do you get access to them
as you request
so series you'll see again i evidenced
in the bundle where um
i've got it here where we there was an
issue
and two lads going in there was brought
in to be police officers at the time i
asked the cctv and i was told that
they thought it was working but it
wasn't and they would get it repaired
we then had further incidents over the
christmas period which have evidence
that again we have the same scenario
where cctv wasn't available
what i can say is
just probably
a week prior to me submitting this
bundle there was an incident inside the
premises where i went along and i spoke
to the licensee and i asked to view
their cctv
you could view it on their system and i
took a pen drive with me to be able to
download it to take that footage away
with me
he couldn't download it he didn't know
the licensee didn't know how to actually
got onto somebody on the phone asking
how to do it and it still couldn't be
done but the response from the licensee
at that time was why didn't you just
send your technical services out to
obtain it and i explained to him we're
not there for that we can't go around
every licensed premises obtaining cctv
footage it should be up to the premises
to deliver it when it's required and
when an incident has occurred um so in
terms of other incidents i cannot answer
whether he has provided cctv to police
and in particularly the last one where
they were fighting inside clearly he's
provided that footage
because that was i took that from an
officer who had previously obtained it
from your from your
opinion in dealing with working with the
licensee
is the 28th day is is the footage being
held
secured securely for whether it be to a
pen drive or on their screen
that a member of the police force can
call in
and see it within 28 days of an incident
or
a request to view from a particular day
within that 28 day time frame is that
being seen i think more recently that's
that's been the case that we have been
able to view it not so much previously
and but obtaining that footage to take
it away is the difficulties that we have
but i do think that it is there i
couldn't answer whether it was for 28
days and maybe mr shaw can answer that
how long it records for but it has been
available recently
okay it could be a question i may ask mr
later thank you thank you
can i ask the officers if they uh have
any questions of the police at this
stage
no
okay well
over to you mr obama
for your questioning
of the
of the police please
thank you um uh
pc packer if i could take you please to
your
um
statement in the bundle which is i think
appendix b
um
reference is made at paragraph four
to your knowledge of the area prior to
you becoming the the licensing officer
and and particularly you you point out
that you knew the previous incarnation
of the venue as as chadwicks
um and alludes you allude to there being
issues with um with chadwicks and the
former owner is that is that right
right yes
yeah
is it possible therefore that um or
would you accept the gmp is therefore
perhaps biased by events that predate mr
shaw's acquisition of the premises
and your view of that particular
establishment
absolutely not what we didn't want is a
repeat of what we had before which is
why prior to
the premises opening as astoria i went
along and i spoke to mr shaw i gave him
all the information as to how it was
being run previously i said that we
didn't want a copy of how it had already
been run and considered that he put
um conditions into place and put a
variation in
so we didn't have a repeat of those
premises i will there was no comparison
as to how he was running it that the
comparison and what we've got now is in
the bundle that's in the evidence but at
that time
when mr shaw first opened those premises
absolutely not and to be honest when mr
shaw first opened those premises the
interpretation was there is a high-end
restaurant with a bar and i specifically
remember talking to mr shaw in those
premises about his prices of beer
gave an indication of the type of
clientele that you're gonna get in there
because generally having two teenage
daughters myself they wouldn't go into a
bar and spend six pounds seven pound on
a gin and tonic would go to somewhere
cheaper so it gives you an idea of the
type of premises there it would be a
high end with nice expensive beers so
absolutely not
okay
and i think you've already addressed
this point
when questioned this evening but you're
whether or not you you've been satisfied
with um with the actions that have been
taken by the the premises your
engagement with mr shaw has been nothing
other than sort of courteous and civil
um paragraph 30 please of your of your
statement um there's reference to um
an incident in october 2019 which i
think
mr shaw
brings to your attention
um and and he actually takes the step of
um
voluntarily or proactively changing the
um
the door staff team as a as a result of
that
and so would you accept that he has
demonstrated that uh well certainly a
degree of control but also
um his proactivity in changing um
changing door staff
i think and if us to read it i think on
that occasion there's an email there and
it's in the bundle where i clarified if
this is the case and i wasn't sure at
that time whether mr shaw was changing
the whole daughty or just one of those
door teams and my understanding was it
just one of those door teams and not the
whole team itself
if that's the incident you're referring
to i'm not aware anywhere where the
whole door team have been changed i know
that one or two have been removed
all right thank you
um paragraph 36 uh please of your of
your witness statement again another
instance where mr shaw is notifying you
of instances
um in this case i think it was too
well whether they were serving greater
manchester police officers or not but uh
some suggestion that they tried to exert
their authority to get into the premises
after hours um
did the police ever get to the bottom of
that do you know
they didn't know because the description
that we got from mr shaw um was quite
vague and we were relying on the cctv so
we could obtain the stills and then make
further inquiries and unfortunately um
that was the occasion where mr shaw was
unable to provide the cctv because he
said that his hard drive had um
had crashed not working whatever
terminology was used and he was only
aware of it at that time when we'd asked
for the footage for it and we did make
follow-up enquiries with a couple of
doors either side to try and obtain
footage of who these individuals were
and unfortunately we couldn't gather any
further information
do you know whether you're just in
response to that do you know whether
your colleagues attended within 28 days
to secure the cctv
in relation to that incident
i seem to remember it was within the
first week
of mr reports in it and
i think
it goes far as to say i think it was
less than a week because mr shaw rang me
direct
that is serious for the police if if
police are using warrant cards to obtain
a privilege i passed it over to a
supervisor immediately mr shaw gave me
the information and i attended um
astoria within a couple of days with the
supervisor with a view that we would
then gather the footage to see if we
could take it further
so yes it was definitely within the week
of it being reported
okay um paragraph um 43 please of your
uh affidavit
um this
refers to
um an email i think you received from mr
shaw
where he raised his concerns about um
policing in the area
um
there
were a number of instances i think or
that he's referred to
um
and
effectively he's concerned that there's
a there's a complete lack of police
presence to to assist his venue or to
assist his
uh door staff with um with their issues
are you able to comment on that
absolutely yeah with all due respect to
mr shaw i think that if mr shaw had put
some of the conditions on his license
and would have complied with those
conditions uh via a voluntary variation
then there's a possibility that the
incidents that were occurring wouldn't
have been as bad as they were and the
police wouldn't have been required but
hey that subject said who knows what
would have happened but you know it's to
me it's up to licensed premises to
comply with the license and objectives
it's not up to please to please
individual premises yes we will help
where it's required and absolutely um i
seem to recall that that weekend that i
did put the overlap shift over on
flixton road and they did police outside
astoria um and mr shaw sent an email to
say thank you very much for it but
please can't please astoria they will
give support where they can but if the
license holder isn't prepared to work
with us by putting policies and
variations into place then it leaves us
struggling as well
yes well i mean that that's that's taken
on board but um
just
the the committee obviously will take
its own view of the of the cctv and um
uh that's been viewed before
hand
but it's right isn't it and i know
you've made comment on it but
throughout at least um
four of the five incidents there's
there's no police presence um at all
there's no passing cars there's no um
there's no officers um that attend the
scene at all which which leaves the
the door staff in the venue to
effectively not as you say not
necessarily police its own venue but
police the street outside and and the uh
and in some instances the um the
pavement on the other side of the road
yeah so most of the calls as you'll see
they've come from traffic council cctv
they're relaying that information to our
control room who then put that
information out to the patrols so
when you see
those facts they're recording live the
police wouldn't be there at that time
they will turn up and i can't give you
time scales in terms of how long it took
them to get there and we know from a lot
of the evidence that's been presented
please do turn up and how long after i i
couldn't answer that but in terms of why
is there no police there on them canvas
it's because it's being recorded live
well again the committee will form its
own viewable it's right isn't it that
some of those recorded instances last
some 15-20 minutes so it's not an
insubstantial length of time for for the
police to to attend
i can't comment on police resources and
the reasons why the maybe 10 may not
have attended
it depends on the demand and and it
depends on how calls come into the
police as well um
so i can't answer that question
paragraph 48 oh sorry sorry i didn't
mean to cut across you then i was just
saying i can't answer that question as
to whether they did how long it took or
maybe why they didn't
okay paragraph 48 please um you make
reference in your um
evidence to uh an agreed ex of what
turned out to be finally an agreed
extension to mr shaw's license on
christmas eve of 2019 uh to 2 a.m
and that that evening went ahead without
incident is that correct
is there any incidents on that date
uh there's no date attached to
it christmas eve christmas eve 2019 when
the uh the license extension the agreed
extension till 2am okay if it's not in
the bundle then no there wouldn't have
been an incident
okay
um
paragraph 53 please um mr shaw
approached you to propose a pub watch
scheme
um
to address the disorder in in the area
that's correct isn't it
yes
uh and your response i think at
paragraph 55 you probably won't agree
with me on this um officer but you
effectively brushed him off didn't you
we haven't got
something the police wanted to do or
were interested in doing
yeah no the police were interested in it
and we did we didn't have a pub watch
scheme in ernst
tried to get one when it first came but
there was a not a big uptake i then
tried to implement the best bar non
scheme
and rather than the pub watch scheme and
there was we did have a
open evening one night where we
councillors came down and we started the
process for a best file on scheme and
and we gave the funding for it
and then the the uptake initially the
update was very high and when it came
down to it i started to get emails to
say the ours didn't feel that they
wanted to participate so
um it's definitely not the case that the
police weren't interested at all we
tried and only recently this year we got
an independent in to go around
dernstance so it was independent from
the police a proper pub watch
coordinator who went around all the
premises service papers on and the
booklets on and tried to get everybody
to join the pub watch scheme and this is
probably i'm sort of guessing but
possibly about six months ago and where
we tried again to get everybody on board
the uptake was zero
now i did attend the premises for
another incident with mr shaw and mr
shaw said that he'd threw his pack away
because he didn't think it was relevant
at that time and when i tried to explain
to mr show the reasons why i wanted a
pub watch and he then says that if you
send me further detail i'll have another
look at it at that point all the other
premises had decided that um they
weren't going to do
going to join it and that wasn't through
me that was through our independent
independent pub watch scheme that
because my view was if we took the
police out of it and got an independent
to try and run it would we then get an
uptake of it and we didn't
so yeah going back to the initial
question you know it's absolutely not
the case that the police brushed it off
and we're not interested i've tried on
three occasions
thank you
um paragraph 64. uh please officer you
you make reference to a visit to the
premises in july
2020
um
you referenced it was a busy evening
with people queuing to get in
um and you
suggested recommended uh told uh mr shaw
to um to tell those people to to leave
was there any particular reason for that
the premises was full uh inside which mr
shaw confirmed it was full uh it was
quite rowdy outside due to the issues
that we have outside anyway um
i'd ask mr shaw is there a likelihood
that those outside are going to get in
your premises tonight and he said no so
i said well why don't you ask them to
leave them why don't you go and tell
them and speak to them that you're
closing your door and those inside will
remain inside and those outside won't be
able to gain entry and that's what he
did he didn't do that so i didn't do it
i asked him if it was the right thing to
do and he agreed and he did it he
complied
and then
unfortunately that that appears to have
sparked a um an incident outside when um
those individuals
um
reacted to being to be refused entry
i'm not no there was no incident that
occurred outside because of the cues
that were outside um and
i'd say how giddy they were
um
i asked the local police fan if he could
come up because i was in plain clothes
so i'd ask the local police fan if they
would come and park up over the road
just to keep an eye on the queue outside
until the door dispersed there wasn't an
actual incident that occurred
okay well thank you
uh paragraph um
70 um
obviously you say that by the time it
gets to july 2020 you've communicated to
mr shaw there that you intend to go for
a review of his premises
um
was was it your unfortunate ill health
the only reason that the review didn't
take place then
absolutely yes
absolutely
i i'm not i'm quite happy to go into it
in terms of yes i did get covered yes i
was under a hospital yes i was under a
a lung unit so it wasn't just a case of
i had kobe for seven days right
that's why the delay was so big because
yes
i did have a problem with it and i
didn't return to work for a considerable
time i was given laptops at home and i
was able to carry on doing my job at
home but i didn't have access to a lot
of the facilities and i certainly
couldn't go and view cctv from traffic
council
but was that was there nobody else at
greater manchester police taking up the
licensing role in your absence
no absolutely not no right okay
okay uh paragraph 74 please um
this
just find the relevant paragraph
um so this is an email
that mr shaw
sends to you may well have been in
response to you notifying him that uh
you were going to seek a review
um
and i'd just like to just to highlight
some of his comments um to you for your
comment please um
mr shaw says that he would like it to be
known that he'd always been amenable and
approachable to the sharing of
information and expertise
um this being evidenced in the fact that
since the reopening of the premises we
have cut short our trading hours on a
friday and saturday night
something that the office is something
that the police actually thanked him for
um
it was explained
um
to an officer sergeant hunt
last week when he came to speak to us
about two males who had caused a scene
outside both of whom were non-patrons of
ours and had not and did not gain entry
to our premises before or after their
altercation
i believe one of these males was also on
top of the vehicle but the officers
present did not feel this warranted an
arrest
he then goes on at paragraph 76 in your
evidence however not everyone on that
street and seen on camera are customers
of ours there is a lot of anti-social
behavior that goes on up and down
flixton road and just because we happen
to be the last one open does not always
make it our fault and and i suggest
officer that that's that's the real
um one of the real key
struts of mr shaw's objection to these
conditions
that um many of these incidents are
being pinned upon the astoria
um when in fact they take place either
outside or on the street outside the
venue which mr shaw has no control over
or they take place when people are
actually refused entry um so in certain
in instances where the door staff are
actually performing their role properly
um
so really it's a question of how on
earth is mr shaw
um supposed to uh effectively police
flixton road in the absence of any
presence of greater manchester police
so i think the the footage speaks for
itself the footage each incident will
show that the patrons that are involved
in those fights um or it's initiated
from astoria and from astorias
um customers and
in relation to everybody else on the
streets we have no complaints we have we
don't have jobs coming in from other
venues on that road i'm not saying none
at all i wouldn't sit here and say none
at all and over the last few years
there's there is some and which they've
been addressed but in terms of the
issues um
with astoria i
specifically
in my bundle i've either provided you
with video footage to show that those
patrons are stood outside i've shown you
video footage um
that then it progresses over the road do
those
other people then when it gets bigger do
they come from other venues or they're
all from astoria i can't answer that
they're behind trees i don't know where
they come from um but it's instigated
from astoria in terms of you talking
about um
refusing entry there's no evidence of a
story ever refusing entry to anybody
because they don't appear to have a
refusal book and i've asked this
question before
for
part of my initial when he first opened
and prayed for opening was that we had
refusal books and various other things
which i've never had sight of
and so if we have used entry to people
we're not aware of that of course it
would help if he's refused entry to them
but he's never put that forward he's
never shown us evidence of it and he's
never put that forward
is that is that not obvious though with
respect officer every single incident
that's been recorded and put to the
committee this evening apart from one
perhaps
refers to incidents happening outside
following ejection so
they are on the um
the incident logs are they not that
these incidents have occurred outside
the premises um and in many instances
when um
individuals have been refused entry
whether or not there's a there's a
refusal book it's clear on the incidents
well it is clear on the incidents that
the incidents occur directly outside the
premises and then spilling to the road
and as my um
solicitor has said hey david on the
majority of those you don't see door
staff at the door so
on those ctvs
um
so if you're now proposing and putting
forward there is some of the basis that
they've been refused entering this is
the first time that that suggestion has
been put forward there is an incident in
particular that we spoke about where it
says they were refused entry but
there is still no control if it is the
case that those customers will refuse to
entry it is still the case that they are
not dispersed they're not separated and
there is no control taken of those that
directly outside the premises
and
so yeah you know
a dispersal book would be very good
wouldn't it because then we'd be able to
tie it back to the incidents and be able
to talk about it i haven't got that
okay
just going off at a side issue and it
obviously ultimately will be a matter
for the committee to decide but it it's
not accepted that
the um
you can't see or the the door staff are
not um visible on the cec tv
um i mean i
there are again the committee will form
its own view but there are certainly
instances there every instance i think
mr shaw would say that there is at least
one if not more
members of the doorstep door staff
presence and also i'm not going to get
into the quality of cctv um you can i
would say just about make out um
badges on arms badges attached to waist
belts uh
belts and things like that so that
it wouldn't be accepted that the the
door staff are not present
or trying to disperse the uh the
incidents
that's the matter for the committee to
decide
would they have a difference of opinion
on that one
you may already have answered this
question already and apologies if uh if
i'm asking you to do it the second time
but at paragraph
81 of your evidence obviously there's a
total of 17 incidents recorded over a
two-year period
um
are you able to say how many of those
the police attended
and if any arrests were made
no not sat here no i can't okay
um you refer um to police intelligence
um of reports of drug dealing out of the
out of the premises um has that
intelligence um being graded at all
it would have been yes
okay
are you able to say
whether it was deemed high quality or
whether it was high-graded or not i
don't know i've not put the grading
system into the bundle so no it would be
a guess which i'm not prepared to do any
any arrests made as a result
in relation to drugs offenses from the
premises as a result of that
intelligence i don't know the answer to
that if intelligence comes in once it's
rated it wouldn't come through me it
would go through a proactive team and
it's not a licensing issue as such
they would deal with it they would um
manage
that intelligence the intelligence
although i can view it a lot of
intelligence gets sanitized and so i get
the the basic crux of it but when it
initially comes in it would go through
to our um
different teams who would then make a
decision to
act on it or not
and that isn't something that would be
shared with me
okay
thank you um
okay um i i know you have already
indicated through your solicitor that
you that you vehemently deny this but i
i have to ask you about it anyway
um
a meeting
was arranged between yourself and mr
shaw i think in early of 2021
um
the when mr shaw indicated he was
intending to to come with a a solicitor
that meeting was subsequently cancelled
um are you i mean are you able to recall
that i think you've already referenced
that you vehemently denied cancelling
any meetings but are you able to comment
on that incident specifically
absolutely no idea what you're talking
about and i would ask have you got
emails as you can see from most of the
community
getting teething straight the
communication with mr shaw has been done
through email and it's kept on file has
mr shaw got evidence of that because
usually that's how we would communicate
and um no not at all
that what you've just said to me
is not familiar to me at all
is there any evidence of that in terms
of emails
well i'll ask mr shaw to comment on that
uh as part of his um
probably his presentation to the
committee uh but you you've given your
response to that so i appreciate that
um you've provided some supplemental
evidence as well uh in reference to
perhaps more recent incidents
um can i just just ask you to clarify
for the committee
those i think that is at um i'm not sure
the name of the appendix but it's a
document entitled incidents recorded
against the premises since the 9th of
december
2021.
are you familiar with the documents i'm
referring to
yeah i need to find it though
let me just first see if i can assist
you with
um
i think it might be appendix c
ah since the 9th of december
yes
yes
so
we have um
what purport to be
three instance three incidents on the
18th of december
okay yes
yeah uh but it's right isn't it on on
considering the the incident logs that
these are
all
all relate to
well they certainly overlap if they're
not the same incident
which accepts that
but it's actually one incident rather
than three on the 18th of december
now they come in at different times
okay well i'll take you through it so
we've got the page
the first one
page one two
three of that of that nine page bundle
is a entitled incident 226 september
18th to december at 17 29 hours
yeah have you got it
yeah
and then the there's a box below that um
with the created on category and
description so that the third entry down
on the 18th of december at 1908
the whoever takes the call says i've
checked on the location and log 206
18 december 2021 seems to refer to the
incident yep
that's put down yet if you turn over the
page
what's reported to be the second
incident is incident 206
was the other
to suggest it's the same incident would
you agree
sorry i'm looking for so we've got
18 19 and 20.
incident number 89 and 20. sorry i'm
confused if you can
go through that again for a minute
no yes so it's um
well i think it's 18 and 19 but there's
two recorded and under 18 for some
reason
no there's one recorded under 18. um
the call came in at
0 1 12 hours
and uh i think let me read it that when
they got there that
mel was intoxicated a small amount of
blood coming from his nose however the
male refused to engage with police and
wanted to go home the male did confirm
that he had been punched by someone who
was no longer in the bar that male
refused to cooperate with the police at
the time the following day so
wherever then underlying the next one
report 18
december 1729
is when that individual rang the police
back to then reports the incident that
he refused
it is the same incident but that's the
same thing
from the above assault later reported
the incidents so i've written that on
the actual bundle
it's not i've not disclosed it's two
separate incidents it is one
well i'm just that's why i'm asking for
clarification so i'm grateful for that
um then incident number 19 incident 0284
yes
this is the same incident again isn't it
so now um
when the police were dealing with the
above incident
incident number
0206 a member of staff from astoria came
out and said i want to report an
incident to you that occurred earlier on
in the night
so it was reported around the same time
but it referred to an incident that had
occurred earlier on to please send out
i'll read them out for you sorry i'm
sorry to have to go to the lens but it's
an important point
incident 206 226 the description here is
offender punches victim four times to
the face cutting inside his lip push his
head into a cupboard causing injury to
lower jaw
and back of head and stamps on his ankle
yeah we then turn to the description of
incident 284
known offender and bastard have heated
discussion in bar offender punches
victim four times to the face cutting
inside of his lip push his head into a
cut causing injury to jaw and stamps on
his ankle it's exactly the same incident
isn't it
so what happened was it is a separate
incident there was a confusion when the
police turned up the police turned up
and dealt with the first incident which
is relates to 0.206
they then spoke to the bar staff and
when they what they didn't do was shout
it up to our communicators whilst they
were there they were also dealing with a
separate incident that occurred earlier
on and there was a confusion in how it
was written up and if you see by the
incident reports that are also attached
to that
it would show that they are separate
incidents
well um
the committee will form its own view but
it's not entirely clear from the uh
yeah i do remember it was a confusion in
the way it was recorded because the
police were there dealing with one
incident the following day
the victim from that range up
and the incidents were crossing over so
that is an error from our reporting of
it our recording of it sorry not
reporting the recording of it but they
were separate incidents
okay all right thank you um you're
through your solicitor you've made
reference to the police's view on the
written representations that were
submitted on behalf of the astoria um
just as a as a general point have you
ever asked to for copies or to see
um the astorias things like training
policy or things like that
i have yes not too long ago i went in
and i asked mr shaw if i could see his
signing in book for
the sia and i noted that he only
recorded four of the numbers and no
names attached to it and that that's the
recent one that i can
remember but
over time yes we've addressed many times
with mr shaw the
as you see from me bundle of where i've
tried to get him to do dispersal
policies i've asked him if things are
recorded um
nothing's ever been put forward
okay um the the issue in relation to
the
um
the requirement for for uh accredited
status
um
what what's that born out of please
what's what's the basis of the
justification for that condition
i think mr ken saudi explained that but
ultimately
we do view sie credited with a specific
um level of service that they provide
and it's
they are trained to a certain level
they are part of a unit if you've got
the sia
accredited then they
they deal with incidents differently
because they're trained to a different
level than somebody who isn't
and
because they're part of the sia what we
generally find is that they don't want
to lose that status so they comply with
what they're taught they comply with
what they implement in bars because they
don't want to lose that sie status so we
find that sia your staff are accredited
acs store staff
behave in a better manner and actually
manage premises the way they're supposed
to manage them
the
requirement for for six door staff um
the
current license requires only
two or minimum of two
is that that's correct isn't it
is it i mean
and yeah so when the premises was
challenged prior to mr shaw taking over
that license was in existence then
it was a change of dps only so the
conditions on that license have been
going back some time i couldn't tell you
how long um but they are
long existing conditions
so when it became a change of dps to mr
shaw those conditions came within which
is why i was asking for a variation
based on
how i perceived those premises were
going to be run at that time
they're not conditions that was agreed
between the police and mr shaw when he
took those premises on they came with
the license that he took over
yes
so
the the current the current proposed
condition if if adopted would require a
three-fold increase in indoor staff or
the minimum requirement for door stuff i
mean in practice it's clear that mr shaw
employs more than two
um but what you're asking
the committee to increase the minimum by
threefold
that's right yes
okay
um are you
might not be relevant to you you might
not be you might not be bothered not to
put too fine a point on it but do you
know that
the the financial cost of
if that were to be uh implemented
well i think you should tell your
comment back that wouldn't be bothered
that's your personal perception and
you're totally wrong but i said maybe i
wasn't i wasn't making the point
my my um
i get employed to uphold the law and to
protect members of the public i don't
get employed to consider finances on
businesses
and as we've seen from the um package
that have presented there is clear
disorder outside those premises there's
disorder inside the premises and my job
is to protect members of the public and
in order to do that my view is that it
would require six doorstep two to stop
those coming in
that don't need to be in there at seven
o'clock because as we all know sometimes
those types of premises that you're
sitting there you might have something
to eat and you stay in there because it
turns into a nightclub so let's stop
those coming in at seven o'clock at nine
o'clock need another two there because
it's player that two isn't enough on the
door there and we need somebody to
manage that external door at the back
and we definitely need somebody inside
to manage the floor and so my view is
based on what's put before us and based
on the evidence that is that i'm privy
to ie footage and information coming
through i feel it needs six again
absolutely that's up to the committee to
make that decision whether they agree or
not
um
it's right
isn't it officer that um
we are
when this case well say case
when
you began your interactions with mr shaw
in in early 2019
there's been a
seismic shift in um
not only the way we all live but but
particularly the way
entertainment premises um
have survived or had to survive
in the face of ever dwindling uh numbers
of um staff or not numbers of staff
sorry numbers of clientele um
has that been factored into your um
proposals um that you've submitted to
the committee or is it the case that
whilst uh
the six the requirement for six m may
have been justified as far as you were
concerned in 2019
uh post pandemic that was certainly no
longer that requirement
would you agree with that oh no and as
i've just said to you i don't consider
finances and i consider based on the
evidence and based on the disorder
that's occurring is where my six come
from now for me um
four weeks ago this package was handed
over for discussions to take place if
they were required and nothing has been
brought to me attention says to give me
any indication as to
the drop fall from customers attending
those premises and
or how that premises has operated or the
change of it since pre-covered so i'm
basing my six on
what i've put before you today because
i've got nothing else to work with
and and if particularly if i was
considering drop-offs because
there's not that many goes out now again
i'd be also considering in that is
finances of premises i don't consider
finances of premises when it comes down
to crime and disorder you know people
have a right to go out and go home
safely and that's what i work off
i'm grateful for to the to the licensing
uh officer to the committee um who's
provided details i don't know if you've
seen them uh officer but details of
um
premises in in the area near astoria
um
but it's right isn't it the of about
seven or eight
other premises in the area some of which
are similar size venues and and contrary
to your assertion uh do suffer uh
similar or issues with with disorder but
none of those other venues in the area
have a requirement on their license to
have any more than two minimum
sia registered door staff
are you able to comment on that yes
those premises haven't um produced the
same amount of disorder
and had they have done i would be
speaking to them in exactly the same way
considering a review of their premises
license
the
uh
if you just bear with me a second please
mrs obama
i know i give you free range with your
question do you have a do you have a lot
more which you have i i don't have any
more sir i'm just going to double check
with mr shaw that uh there isn't any
burning questions he wants me to ask as
a result of
um that but i i'm finished now so if you
just allow me a brief moment
yes okay
thank you so i don't have any more
questions
okay okay thank you well it's now your
turn to put your representations i don't
know if you want to take a breath or do
you need
no no i think given the time we'll we'll
press on so if that's okay so i think we
might be kind of limited to could i just
ask the legal officer do we have to have
a time limit on the meeting
um no there isn't a time limit um but
you may feel that it gets to a time
where
um you might
think it's appropriate to adjourn and
reconvene
if it gets too late
um but there's there's no time limits
now i know some meetings are standing
orders for half past nine but we'll try
and aim for yeah i think that's when
it's um it's an in-person meeting in the
uh and that's to do with the the
buildings and and such like but as far
as i'm aware um
i'm prepared to stand corrected by our
governance officer that on the standing
orders but um
yeah i don't believe there's a time
limit
okay
okay we'll we'll press on them for now
can um
okay mr barnum sorry i didn't i didn't
hear that so was that was that that
you you you'll adjourn after half past
nine is that we could have the option to
do it and then come back to deliver our
verdict
or even in writing but uh you know it's
it's up to us really so we'll see how it
goes and hope that we can try and
achieve half past nine or thereabouts
so yeah okay well
i'm going to
ask mr shaw at this stage to
um
present the the astoria's um
representations with with some questions
um for him from myself um
so
it's not the best presentation i
apologize but uh if you can both
see and see and hear or certainly hear
um mr shaw's response um we'll we'll
press on um
mr shaw um
[Music]
you've heard the
issues and objections that have been
raised um
by greater manchester police um
obviously
since the
incidents
began in 2019 there have been
a
number of things that you have
implemented and changed um to the
license so are you able to um address
the committee on what what steps and
what term what
changes you put in place to to address
concerns yeah look the first thing i'll
say is that i acknowledge that there are
there are or were failings i'm not sat
here saying that
that there hasn't been or challenging
that rather
however a big
thing for me so basically my background
is he's not in the
licensee world it's completely different
um
so i i've done what i can i'll i'll hold
my hands up at times probably not the
best i'm i'm not going to sit here and
say otherwise what i would say is a big
thing that i have brought in is a more
experienced dps
a stronger dps with a lot more
and a pre-existing relationship with
um traffic licensing or great advantages
to licensing and i do think since her
arrival in
november
yeah
it has it has operated a lot differently
a lot stronger with a lot more i think
the
gmp solicitor says the chaotic or bedlam
i think a word was that he used um i
would argue that that isn't the case any
longer i do see that i do see the venue
as improving
um
so much so the
stable steps we've taken to to achieve
that is mean that we have employed at
times when when risk assessed more door
staff than is required
okay
[Music]
the
i don't know if there is a requirement
for a minimum level of
staff on on a sunday
but you've obviously raised an issue
over having a minimum of of
well four or six
staff on on a sunday can you just
clarify that well i think the average
takings on a sunday sit around 800
pounds
if six door stuff and let's let's let's
i'll i'll be uh transparent here you're
looking at around 20 pounds per hour
so six times so you're looking at 120
pounds per hour multiplied by if you
come on at seven the leave at one um
because we shot at 12 so what is that
five hours is it yeah
no it's 96
that's six that would seem my lit
security cost of 720 pounds for a sunday
well taking the taking the cost
to one side
well what about this um
sorry um
observing and managing next to nobody
right so the weather what i would say is
should some days and obviously looking
at an average take of 800 pounds that's
a concern to me so it should be busier
should they become busier then yes
properly risk assessed people put more
stuff on yeah okay
just address please the um the issues
over the
the security company um
that was employed slash is now employed
well
actually rather than getting in
going too far into that and and i do
take take on board karen's comments
if and if an acs operating hcs is the
phrase isn't it yeah if the acs firm
operates in the way that
miss packer and
her solicitor say they do then you know
i actually think that's a good thing
okay so i wouldn't if
i would
put that on the table i'm not really
you'd agree to that i would i would
agree i would remove the doc and the
firmware on now i've watched the videos
as soon as everybody else
i'm not saying they're not trying just i
just don't think they're effective
enough
so i would happily change that
thank you
um
just address please the
police's proposal to bring forward the
closing time of the of the venue
well it would be
you know we are a large
or one of the larger capacity venues on
on that street
if we were then
if the terminal was to be brought
forward it would be in line with other
larger venues so i do think there'd
probably be a bigger issue on the street
because there'll be more people to
police
up and down not just outside my door
and
i know obviously you're saying cost
isn't something that you you take in
mind but of commercial commercials
however we do employ a lot of local
people you know almost have 15 to 20
staff on the books including
entertainment and such as other such
things um
losing that final hour which is quite
profitable for me
would result in job losses
okay
the
um just address please the committee in
relation to the concerns over the rear
door
concerns
well
you heard that the police suggested
sorry the police yes sorry sorry that's
been used as an egress and it's not it's
not it's not user's egress the body cam
footage from 2019 was
as dc packer writer said was after the
event so the reason people were outside
is because we've had to
sort them into now inside that's why
they were then outside sometimes that
door is a quicker option to remove
people
uh it is under cctv so if anybody wants
to remove there you would see the
solicitor mentioned that there were bins
and other such things out there yes
there was and yes there are right now
because it's not used as a smoking area
should should we
transform that into small care then of
course there wouldn't be objects and
other bits of furniture and such as
which which could be used as anything
else and can you address pc packers
comments about the suitability of that
yard as a as a
as a drink well not drinking but an
outside area well the proposed smoking
area would only be where
my car and another staff member's car is
our cars would be moved and that would
be that would form a smoking area so i
don't see how if it would be a problem
to the drivers
to any anybody else using that for that
yard because
our cars are already there in the first
quest so there wouldn't be obstructing
anything
it would also only be used with
a
pc packer right i said during the day it
is a busy ad sorry
there should be a caveat on that that
would only be used on on an evening
friday saturday evening would that would
be the smoking out to relieve
um
yeah congregation on the front thank you
um i'll take the next few
together for the sake of brevity
can can you do you have any comment in
relation to the uh the proposal
to remove furniture from outside to
remove the requirement for external
drinking and the exclusive use of
polycarbonate vessels rather than glass
yes furniture
i think
we're putting the proposal in with that
with that we brought in at nine o'clock
and that's been happening for some time
now
um
so that if that's not even out because
of the weather however
yeah it would it would be brought in at
nine o'clock or whatever time that may
be agreed
uh that's quite the
uh drinking in external areas drinking
external areas yeah i don't i don't want
drinking on the on the front pavement
other than
i sat at those tables at those times
after that i don't finish some drinks
outside that will be a job for the uh
door staff and management to ensure
doesn't doesn't go ahead okay
they
potential requirement for polycarbonate
vessels as opposed to glass
it would be an expensive cost to
implement
again
you know it's not something that
shouldn't be considered cost
and i do think it actually would um
whilst it might not
i'd do a word this correctly
i think if you walked into a venue and
it had plastic glasses i think you would
assume that there was going to be
trouble anyway i think it probably
attracts the wrong people
okay
yeah thank you
um
the
can you just address the the committee
please there's been some discussion with
regard to
you know the the police not having seen
any policies or or procedures
um
can you just address what if any steps
have been taken to
um to provide those or
the existence of requests for those
i'll address the first one regarding the
door staff signing in book
it was noted that um so they have a 16 i
think 16 digit number on on the badge
for the benefit of the committee
this that's quite a long number and the
box is quite small to fill that in four
they put their number at the front of
the book it remains at the front of the
book and when they come onto the ship
they just put the last four digits on
that was picked up on in the summer i
believe
when pc packer attended since then that
hasn't happened i always ensure that the
phone number gets gets inputted in
uh as far as training manuals training
documents right to serve and all the
anything around that
i wasn't the way i had to share that
with you i'm more than happy to share
that with you we do have we do hold
those those training manuals um i wasn't
aware that during this 28-day
consultation period we would be sharing
those i thought off the back of this
review
that's when we would have to make
amendments and possibly share them then
so there's a
no there's been no reluctance to share
anything
thank you
um
the
existence or otherwise of a dispersal
policy um are you able just to explain
to the committee what what steps have
been taken in relation to that
i agree these for more robust
um
in the proposal we welcomed the
involvement from gmp we could
at least work together on on building a
more robust and more of a roundtable
discussion as to how how we achieve this
um what we have done is take on board a
security consultant
um who has been advising us in the last
couple of weeks as to what what we would
need to do
um how to enter the venue in a more
um
in a safer manner let's use that one of
a better purpose
so yes whilst we don't have
one properly written up at the moment
there is one in in the draft stages and
that we will be sharing this
thank you
are you able to
comment uh or do you have any comments
for the committee in relation to
what they've seen on the cctv the
four or five instances on on cctv
you have any comment in relation to that
yeah a lot of it is to do with ejection
and refusal um
the ones that you've quite said that are
going on something some 15 20 25 minutes
and there is no police attendance um
it's not for me to discuss the police
form your own opinion on that
okay
in in general
what is what is your view on the
you um to be careful how you you phrased
this but you're you able to sort of
summarize or explain to the committee
your interactions with with greater
manchester police and the licensing team
and how you felt they've gone
i feel that when the police do attend
the police aren't there to actually make
arrests i think the police are there to
find
or look for feelings on our parts
which
whether rightly or wrongly that is a
sentiment that i feel and i do feel that
it's worth noting
i on many occasions have given police
cctv i've given them names and addresses
of offenders because i've gone and found
that out myself
and i'm yet to see many arrests made on
incidents that happen
just just going back to the cctv from
one matter that was raised i think in
particular um
are you able to comment on um or respond
to the comments that the door staff
aren't aren't visible uh or aren't don't
appear on the cctv the incidents
certainly do appear on the cctv you can
see the badges reflecting
um are there any comments to
sorry
however too
completely eradicate this this this
issue or suggestion uh we have ordered
hiv jackets so that they will be wearing
those in the future
thank you
was there a comment you wanted to make
mr shaw
in relation to the the issue that was
raised right at the the start of the
meeting with regard to body worn body
worn cameras
yeah well
yes that was sort of
sorry
sorry just yeah we're back yeah it's
still done
sorry we just froze then can everyone
still see and hear us
yeah yeah yeah sorry thank you
yeah we will we'll put the we will
ensure that body body cams are made
available for the uh for the door staff
um
on evenings when door staff ants
working the manager
who's on shift will be wearing a body
camera
okay
um
just
a final uh point mr shaw
quickly drawing to the end of our 15
minutes
if if the conditions are um
adopted or the proposed the police's
proposed conditions are adopted in full
what what practical effect will that
have on on
on the premises
thank you so i think that
moves we may have concluded a minute or
two shorter than 15 minutes but uh
if anyone has any questions of uh of mr
shaw
yeah oh sorry sorry what there was
another matter sorry sorry can you just
one last question i do apologize um can
you just um explain um to the committee
please what steps have been taken in
relation to
um staff
i hope since uh kate has been employed
as a gps
there has been wholesale staff changes
i don't actually think that there is one
staff member still working there
could correct me but i don't think there
is
um there's also
quite an excessive bad list so as we all
know and i'm sure i'm sure karen is
aware of some of these people
um
on those cctv there's a lot of faces
that crop up again again and again
and these are these four most of our
well kate's bad list now so steps have
been taken
rather subjective
how many how many people are actually on
that bard list now
just yeah just under 20. but from those
videos i
i quickly jotted down there must be 15
of what we've seen on the video who are
now
not permitted to enter the premises uh
yes thank you
thank you thank you apologies thank you
very much and any questions for mr shaw
yeah um
i've got a few uh i can't be brief right
you mentioned the change of the
dps to uh
ms davis i believe
yeah
as of the licensing authority been
notified all of that because yes
[Music]
the licensing authority not the police
because i'm sorry i do apologize
the variations
as
it's something we can
we can deal with
um you mentioned sunday
um
and you're saying that
you think it's a
bit of overkill to um
for the the requirements on a sunday are
you saying that sunday's less busy than
a friday and saturday because you said
you only
date two
thousand
yep
massively sure yeah
yeah huge huger
quieter so is is is the is the issue
that there's not such a there's not such
a problem on a sunday than there is on a
friday and saturday
well i didn't see on the cctv an
incident on a sunday night going into
monday morning
right and you you're open the same times
though
we close at 12 on a sunday
as opposed to one
right okay so right there maybe some
differentiation there in terms of the
furniture you said that you prepared to
bring them in at nine o'clock
which is fine but i mean how would you
control that practically if somebody sat
outside having a drink
you can't just come and take the tables
up there can you
would you ask them to go inside or what
how would that actually work
we would probably if somebody noticed
somebody sat down at half past eight
with a drink we probably would tell them
that
look at nine o'clock this furniture is
coming in
uh i think an easy one is probably just
uh get some signage
right okay
in any case we'd communicate that with
whoever was using that furniture at that
time
you mentioned refusals and you said that
you've
you've got you've made lots of refusals
but there's no evidence
so
how is that going to be recorded i mean
you offered um
sort of voluntary conditions on other
stuff such as training
but you didn't mention
the refusals
policy or refusal log
are you willing to take that just if
not contested then just take that as
agreed uh there will be i think kate's
already implemented her if he was a log
yeah she's
[Music]
yeah i agree with looking on the cctv
they probably do be more visible yeah
100
no problem though
right okay i'll just ask
any of my
final colleagues about any questions yes
chip okay
uh i've got a couple of questions one is
uh
have you kept a log of incidents over
the past
yes we've got we've got an incident book
right uh and has that
has that been shared
or do you
have you found it sometimes uh where you
might have thought it important to
relate it to the uh
police to let them know of any instance
you know
from your own initiative so to speak
apart from calls that we make ourselves
yeah
but sir and when police have attended we
do give them the incident book and the
and have you uh been asked any time to
provide a contact number for local
residents
i mean
whether you do
from local you know a resident who was
in the in the vicinity who may have
complained about the noise and
disturbance or
any
rowdiness
do you have any kind of communication
with them
or have do they have something
if a complainant
came to ourselves and yes yes of course
i have communication with them oh we did
have um a noise complaint
um i
called
peter bellfield was with his name with
the environment the eho
but in that time one of the local
residents actually made himself known to
me and that that is
the amendments that are now going on the
license regarding the noise and the
shutting the windows and such that was
something that i sat down with this
president and we saw just
brainstormed back together so yeah there
is communication with people
and when i know who they are yeah and
they have a contact number for you if
you do you give it out to them or do
they
not not a personal mobile number because
there's a couple of times
which is available online and on our
social media pages
all
right
okay as well as email addresses
thank you
thank you
councillor thomas
yeah be brief because
a few of the questions i wanted have
been answered already
um just a
quick question do you or the designated
door staff feel that the dispersal
outside the premises is more of a police
matter than yourselves
i think it's something we could probably
all work together on
because i i'm just going to take this
he was late alleged to by uh i'm sorry
mr obama
um
that you you feel that
all the premises in the same location
aren't being hit with that but from our
point of view this is about this premise
is not other premises
if you understand what i'm saying so
that's how many temporary event notices
have you applied for that have been
refused
no
you've not had any reviews
okay no that's fine thank you
there's just one more
question that i'd like to ask you
mention you're happy for the doorstop to
wear body cameras
yes but you didn't mention a number so
what what sort of ratio would you that
be happy for all of them or half of them
or
what happening well
well what i thought we would probably do
would have two door staff wearing one
and the manager on on that on shift that
evening
two-door staff and the manager
yes
well the manager wearing a body cam
manager wearing a body cam is that what
you said sorry
it's getting late is that what you see
is that what you said that you were
happy for
the two-door staff and the on the
manager
yes yes i did say that right okay just
clarifying that
okay thank you um do any of the officers
have questions for the licensee or the
representative
no questions from the licensing officer
chair
okay thank you can i now ask the police
if they would like to uh
question the uh the licensee and his
representative please yeah please thank
you but once i longer talk um very
conscious about time um so from what
you've um just said can i take you that
you would now agree
that an acs door company may be a good
idea
i do
yeah from viewing the footage and
listening to how you have said they
operate then you have 100 angry on that
yeah
okay great thanks um also with regards
to the rear door and the concerns we
have there
um
i mean obviously just i was obviously
pointing out before that these um these
yellow light double yellow lines so it
looks like it's an area for vehicles
it's for cars
right outside the door
leading into the back fire exit it's
double the other lines right across the
across the back so
it's not a public area it where you can
go
standing and setting up a pedestrianized
area it's a road
my car's parked there for probably 15
hours a day and i don't get a ticket uh
it's actually documented in my list that
the
leaseholders of
32 to 34 flixon road have always enjoyed
the use of that area for parking um but
i'm just a bit
can i say
can i ask a question
what's
is it not a good thing that the smoking
areas at the rear are not at the front
is that not that is that better all
around
before it's agreed and the committee
agree i'm just saying are you actually
able to facilitate that can you actually
provide it are you allowed
is that your area to provide it well i
just think it needs to be
checked there are
there are markings where we
agree to something
the studs in the floor
which actually is as far as our barrier
goes so
yeah whilst there may be double yellow
lines there we are allowed to use that
space that is i i have skips there bins
cars
yeah all sorts of things that's just
it's just it's an observation i'm not
completely without what i'm saying is
that area looks like it's not it's not
for pedestrians it's not for people to
go out there i mean there's a smoking
area so you just think about but the gas
is smoking area anyway so obviously
there'd be no tables no
no tables out there
no no no no no just walk and leave yeah
you take any glasses outside
no drinks will be left inside
kind of a cctv footage so exactly where
the drinking soda because obviously you
can check it
check
i can check what sorry
you could check
sorry you could check with the guys to
anybody taking any drinks outside any
glasses etcetera and also would you ever
we will also make sure that there is a
security
man or woman on that door
and would you have a control on numbers
as well
um
i don't know the number at the moment i
don't know what regulations are but yeah
but there would be controller numbers
yeah okay other point which we've um
discussed and you've been linked to
yourself as a polycarp
[Music]
apologies for that but i've just gone
back onto the laptop so um thank you
are you all right all right now to
continue yeah sorry yeah so uh yeah
polycarbonate you discussed it earlier
um so you won't have an issue with
polycarbonate either is that correct no
i would have an issue with polycarbonate
right
why would you have an issue with
polycarbonate what's the concern with
regards to that aspects i don't i feel
it's excessive um it's also expensive
and it does you know if we are to be
if you know as you the word didn't used
uh improve the venue then i don't think
it would improve i think you would
actually lessen it i think you would
cheapen it
but
i think i think you're mistaken on that
point i'll be honest with you because
i've done licensing applications all
across great manchester and a lot of the
city center bars have polycarbonate you
can get a good quality polycarbonate and
it doesn't reflect and also you get less
breakages etcetera everything else
on various occasions that polycarbonate
so it is a relative expense at the start
but afterwards
is significant the same as it can be
delivered i've been advised of other
bars who've taken the polycarbonate when
they've gone through that i'm not an
expert just saying that's the interface
to be provided with
so if you are looking to be a
different establishment more high-class
establishment would it not make sense to
have
polycarbonate especially good quality
strong polycarbonate with regards to
that aspect
because you've had blasting you've had
you've had incidents there before with
glass and people have been walking
of the 17 incidents
how many were how many how many were
glass related
there was
i think it was for the glass-related
contest i don't think there was that's
the list
look at something wrong
let's get the list
i'll come back to that so list
the exact numbers
but what i would say is we would risk
assess such as when there's a you know a
big sporting event or
yeah
yeah we
would bring polycarbonate for those
evenings
sorry yeah the incident sorry the
incidents were incident seven relates to
a pound last being thrown which smashes
that's a place 56 of the bundle incident
eight refers to cctv cctv the observable
disturbance where the glass is smashed
that's page 56 as well
um
incident same was witnessed by police
customers walking around outside with a
glass bottle of champagne that's a page
57
um
part of
not allowing glasses and outside once
after a certain time
or glass but
these flash classes are they used as are
they used as weapons or is it just a
smash class
an incident 11 refers to a female being
bottled on the head and the second
female hits it ahead with a bottle
that's this is 11. there have been
incidents where there is one incident
for instance so far it says if there's
one incident somebody's injured with a
glass
you should be using polycarbonate
because of the manner in which is which
occurred in those premises that's enough
for the committee that's what it is yeah
i agree that's for the country
there's a lot of places where they have
without people at glaston i don't i
don't always think they get enforced
polycarbonate church your colleague has
had his hand raised for some time i
don't know if
sorry i'll just uh
i don't know i'm just
going to scare you
the police have finished uh
um the other question really was regards
to the furniture outside as well um
obviously take it at nine o'clock
how are you going to manage and i think
it's been alluded to already by um
by the councillor with regards to how
you got to deal with
that furniture outside because
where the furniture's situated where
your premises are situated you're
nearers you're nearly directly on the
crossing over the road
so how are you going to direct is how
many people can stand outside and use
those
tables in question and obviously you're
gonna need a policy with regards to that
and a consideration i wouldn't would it
just not be better to have nobody
drinking outside when you've seen the
incidents that already occurred out
there
and the
issues
as well four tables two chairs at
maximum of eight people sat down
are you gonna control that
well we'd say
where you'd control anything would just
tell them that sorry it's full out here
you're going to have to go inside
because that's a
and obviously i'm sure you'll produce a
policy if you're the guy how are you
going to deal with that because it's
going to be part of
what your policies are going to suggest
to you but the fact is that if you've
already had concerns before with regards
to individuals who have been turned away
or had disagreeable information passed
to them and they've caused incidents how
are you going to deal with that aspect
when you get to a certain point where
you just refuse to just refuse any more
service or refuse service in the first
instance
if it's already full if those seats are
already taken we'll just refuse service
if if we know you know if the highlights
are going to go and sit there
yeah and with regards to it's just about
communication really with the individual
right okay i'll leave that point with
you i'll leave you with the committee
because obviously we have a concern with
regards to that aspect and then the
final
aspect we'll notice as well this would
only be up until 9 00 pm so would there
be no late night drinking out there i
think that'll be worth the committee uh
noting
yeah
one of the incidents was at half past
eight though the first incident where
the two lads ran off and
came back and dropped back the car they
were refused entry as well
they never entered the premises
okay
what we could have done with that one
yeah so the final the final point i've
got is in relation to the policies
and
even you've mentioned the facts of you
have um
the policies in place you have the sia
door book where obviously the numbers
weren't written down and that's
obviously changed now and you've
mentioned it they were written down and
deborah
i think you pronounce it surname she
actually she looked it and at first
things was oh they're not writing the
numbers down she then went to the front
of the book said oh no actually they're
doing this and then she said to me is it
possible can they just fill the full
numbers in i said not come at home
okay um i've not seen that book and the
committee's not seen but i understand
that you say it's being completely house
effect i wasn't i wasn't aware we had to
we had to bring the book with us
i had to know and then of course i would
have brought that the police in the book
because it's actually it's it's situated
at the front of our premises and it's
always available
right well
this is my last point for us um let's
see everybody
with regards to policies
you've not got a policy for refusal a
refusal book it's not a training staff
but it's not a dispersal policy it's not
a drugs policy
um with regards to the cctv footage um
which has been mentioned within your
documents you have concerns with regards
to certain people
underneath the cctv
because if you no no no i think i think
that's been misinterpreted there's not
concerns to searching people on the
camera there's absolutely no issue with
that i'd rather search people from the
camera
the concern that michael raised was what
if you catch them in an area that isn't
covered by a camera whilst we do have a
lot of cameras in any case in any place
in any area there are black spots if we
find them in a black spot are we to say
sorry can i move you to this camera so i
can search it
so i can take these drugs off yeah i
don't think so we do search people at
the door they do find ways to to get
things in in any venue not just my own
so what you're going to do as
individuals if you find them in the
toilets
and you think that dealing drugs what
are you going to do with the individual
well not dealing drugs i don't
i've never caught anybody dealing drugs
i've caught people taking drugs or my
doorstep have and the consumer
individuals
you're sorry
what you're going to do with those
individuals instantly eject them yeah
right well that might be the position
might save what i'm saying to you is
that cctv at the front door
is an important aspect of the regards to
protecting yourself you'd seem to
without the front door though
when you see them coming out the front
door when we attack them
yeah
okay so the
search policy is and i think this needs
to be some
confusion there
there's not a reluctance to search
people under a camera or in front of a
camera i'm just saying what if in that
instance they're not on camera
it's difficult isn't it that can you
understand that the practicality of that
you know sorry can i move you into that
from what you've said in your discussion
from what you said in your paper it does
sound contentious so what you said come
across that word than my apologies i'm
not i'm not being contentious over
i'd rather just come in a minute can i
just ask the questions we've got we're
going to be employing body cameras
aren't we so most of us going to record
on that anyway whether it's in the
toilets or anywhere else
i think you're talking about a point now
the question is quite simply are you
agreeable to the cctv and the search is
being said undertaken when they're
coming to the premises with regards to
drugs 100 yeah right that's it that's
that's the point the other point is with
the garcia policies
right we've not seen and the committee's
not seen a single policy
no policies whatsoever
and there's none at the moment that are
written have been provided
so we've not got one for the sia door
stuff we've not got a refusal book we've
not got training for staff also training
for staff what training you're going to
provide to staff
okay
we have an incident book we have a log
book we have an accident book we have a
search policy we have a dress code
policy that's actually displayed on the
door uh we carry out staff training and
we also have licensed licensee trainings
we're sending some more stuff on
licensing courses are they they're
written documents everything's occupancy
and we've never been there
if there was a request and of course it
right if you can provide those documents
to us in any event that could be agreed
yeah yeah as a committee
so
you've got drugs
refusal training staff dispersal policy
drugs policy you're going to have
obviously cctv as well to agree to the
cctv so the only points of contention
are six door staff
and
the reduction of one hour
yeah yeah
that's correct
well i mean there are other issues but
it seems like we may be
reaching compromise on those but uh
there's issues over the outdoor drinking
external drinking as well
yeah
external drink as well sorry
as well so everything else is agreed so
all i would say is that with regards to
our position we'd need to see those
policies all those policies
before
we'd be happy to match the speed any
further
as well as everything else obviously in
the polycarbonate but i think that
covers everything committed so
i think we're
pretty much finished we'll know we're
nowhere now
okay thank you mr kent um
uh councillor thomas you have a question
then councillor but
yeah thank you chair uh
a couple of quick questions uh obviously
regarding the smoking area which
obviously although the residential
properties to the back that's not
something we can consider as a committee
because that's the main issue and the
land is private land owned by eden
square
which is probably why you're not getting
the tickets when you lease
i'm also concerned that if you're going
to have egress and access there fire
doors so
to the rear
you have fire doors which should be
short
so that would be something that would
concern me in in even though it's
a step forward in my opinion going on on
here
i would like to just tell you the
polycarbonate and i have experience in
this because in a previous
previous job i used to sell
polycarbonate glasses they're actually
work out
i don't know so it's not touching for
business
but they're actually cheaper they watch
better and they last a lot longer than
glass so
polycarb not flexi glass would be a very
good addition to your stock you would
have so many last breakages and it will
cost you a lot less money in the long
term but the main question that i've got
about this is
you're extolled that you have
many of the policies in place
uh although you contend that you've not
been asked for them the police obviously
contend that they would like to see them
uh what sort of time frame can they be
brought in and also
if
uh at the outcome um this is good we
could have that we could have them over
to you in in the morning
but not to me to the to the police staff
to the yes
24 hours we have those with you right
sorry sorry yeah
well
we'll take it as read that you mean
everybody involved yeah
also
there are other things in in here that
may or may not occur additional
conditions
such as acs
door staff uh increase
potential increase of door staff uh
taking into account what you said about
your sunday trading what sort of time
frame we were looking at for you to
implement
the content the contentious issues that
would have been raised towards the end
i appreciate we're not going to i don't
need to say to me it's going to be
it and
these conditions haven't been applied
yet so hypothetically
what sort of time frame we're looking at
i think you may need to be a bit more
specific sir on that if it's a specific
question as to how soon
mr shaw could get an acs accredited firm
in then that may be one he could answer
um in terms of how quickly he could get
an additional two staff um on
weekends or you know up to six then um
i'm not sure that's that's that's a
question he's able to answer um
um and it may not be one that ever gets
answered if the venue ultimately has to
close
it you know so
i think by um accepting or answering
that
yeah i'm not sure that's what he can
answer
okay i appreciate that i was
because we we haven't discussed what the
conditions are going to be i was just
looking to ascertain
whatever is eventually agreed any we
will take priority
okay thank you thank you very much
okay thank you
uh
a couple of points um
one is you know they
clearly there's a few
areas that you need
your uh
terms of reference for uh which have
been alluded to
are you able to access any templates as
a from the offices or
if you if you're finding it difficult to
have any kind of um
um
acceptable
policy you know for you
for the policies that have been uh
loaded to you know
absolutely i think if i would if i can
answer that so i think the the answer to
certainly the vast majority of those
policies is that they have them the
issue that the contention seems to be
whether or not they've been asked for
before or seen but what they're
certainly available um as far as a
dispersal policy i think it's referred
to in um in the um
[Music]
in the written representations that uh
um
uh
sort of representations or cooperation
has been saw or input's been sought from
greater manchester police on that which
hasn't been forthcoming
right
in terms of some of the video evidence
or the cctv footage we saw there was
it's particularly inside the premises
there was a fracas going on near to the
nearest bottom right
which was in a blind spot uh
it seems that you don't seem to have
sufficient cctv
covering the uh the premises within and
you know and as people seem to know
where the blind spots are and the
activities taking place there
and we're just sort of
trying
which incidents
wasn't it that you saw yeah
did you not have any kind of cctv on the
other side of the the the the room there
yeah
the police were shown this but it was
from a distance it didn't it wasn't the
best but the police were showing this
all right okay now i appreciate you know
the
similar situation outside where they
it's almost like people knew where the
blind spots were when they would go
around the corner if they wanted to sort
of become violent uh with anybody in
particular or
uh nearer to sort of bottom right again
and perhaps you know that it would have
been better for the council to have uh
cctv on one of the corners there where
they could get to
view
uh along the back
i think that's that's perhaps
no no that's not for you
all right sorry sorry yeah okay
yeah okay yeah that's fine thanks much
yeah
okay all right now
i think we finished the
representations and the questioning so
i'm going to ask both parties to
summarize and you've got two minutes so
we'll start with the
licensee representative if you could
summarize your case in two minutes
please
was that from the police sorry you asked
the police to go first sir well no the
pl the police are the applicant
effectively i know it's a bit
about face because it's not it's not a
usual licensing hearing so the police
have put the application for the review
so they they're effectively the
applicant so they get the last say so if
you're very good yeah well i hope my two
minutes starts now then rather than
ask that question i'm sorry
yes well um
can i refer the committee as i'm sure
they're familiar to the um
the section 182 uh the licensing act
guidance that's been issued by
manchester city council in particular
paragraph 1120 which can be found at
appendix eye of the of the hearing
bundle
um
that
paragraph is one i commend to the
committee because it states that
remedial action should be
directed at the causes and perhaps more
importantly as far as this submission
goes it should always be no more than an
appropriate and proportionate response
to the causes of concern that gave rise
to the review so uh taking that uh point
um uh members of the committee i would
submit that um
whether or not uh greater manchester
police
have a wish list of conditions and that
may be
a pejorative term and the the committee
are invited in my submission just to
adopt
those conditions um that are no more
than appropriate and proportionate
response to the concerns
um and i'd ask the committee to to bear
that
in mind
the um
i'll refer you to um the the written
submissions that were prepared and
served yesterday uh of course the
committee now are aware that there has
been a degree of movement um in respect
of that now we're a long a lot way
closer than perhaps we were
before those submissions were prepared
mr shaw has
today accepted uh quite rightly in my
view that there have been some legacy
issues uh and continuing issues from the
bars and previous incarnation as
chadwicks which which mr shaw is trying
in my respectful submissions is best to
overcome uh in the face of challenging
circumstances uh particularly in the
last 18 months it's clearly evidence
that his desire to cooperate with the
police he has made positive steps by
removing the dps which was a a
particular concern to a greater
manchester police
and has changed the the the door staff
company
and obviously you're aware from what he
said tonight that he's prepared to take
that extra step and and employ only acs
credited firms moving forward
many of the conditions that were
proposed
have been accepted those that perhaps
are contested
um are not simply through any um
bull-headed um
issues on mr shaw's side that they are a
real genuine concern that they would
force the
the premises to close but even in that
regard mr shaw has not simply refused
them outright um he has um
offered uh what i would submit are
pragmatic uh um uh
compromises specifically in relation to
the number of staff the external
drinking
and things like that
the the majority of these incidents um
seem to
have been attributed to the astoria
simply because it's the only bar
left open
um but
as i think mr shaw alluded to bringing
the the bars terminal hour forward an
hour in line with all the other bars in
the area
i think would not um
reduce
um the concerns or the public disorder
and in fact would go some way to
increasing them given that um even more
individuals would would be buying and
fighting for um
for taxis um
bus cues taxis trains things things of
that nature
um they would only overstretch and
already stretch police force as even
more people um
congregate um on the street from other
establishments
um i would respectfully submit that the
conditions
um proposed in in the document prepared
by mr smith by mr shaw um
aligned with his his comments and
further concessions he's made in the
meeting today
do go uh far enough they are practical
they are proportionate and they do i
would submit adequately address the
issues raised by greater manchester
police
um
those sir are my submissions
thank you very much
um
could i ask the
police to make their closing
surveillance please
uh yes uh committee um i think obviously
you've heard you've seen the evidence
you've heard the evidence there are
concerns that there were concerns with
the premises are our concerns with the
premises and regards to the management
if those conditions are implemented
which we have suggested we feel it will
deal with those concerns
most of those conditions have now been
agreed the points of contention are
polycarbonate i would suggest number of
door staff
and the reduction in hours
and also the outside furniture as well
is obviously a point the other point of
note is the
policies
which are required obviously we've not
seen those policies yet um so that comes
on to the point of
the
closure
until all the conditions
are in place
and implemented
and that's probably the only point that
great master police would make is that
before
the premises
open
it should be closed until everything not
available
apologies can i just come back on that
very final point with the committee's
leave
yeah yeah it's simply to say that um and
i think it's referred to in our written
representations that uh
we would ask the
any conditions that are adopted by the
committee that rather than the bar the
premises be licensed be suspended um
pending the completion of those because
you know no disrespect to greater
manchester police but
there has been from experience some
delay
from the completion has been
the conditions being complied with to
the police actually getting around to
sanctioning them and signing them off
i would ask that rather than suspend the
license pending the completion of those
conditions that uh a period of time is
allowed
perhaps 28 days
it is allowed um within which those
conditions are complied with
failing that uh suspension
if that's the power of the committee
could be uh imposed at the conclusion of
that of that period of time say 28 days
but as far as the policies are concerned
i think the offer was that they could be
handed over within 24 hours
in any event
okay thank you mr obama
right does that conclude that concludes
the police
presentation doesn't it um
hello somebody speak
i don't know i was just saying thank you
okay sorry here thank you um well
clearly it's been a long night there's
been a lot said we we now have to retire
uh into a breakout room to discuss our
decision
um i think one of the first things we
would discuss is how we're going to
relay
that decision to you it might be that we
we don't do it in the conventional way
given the time so i think that's the
first thing to discuss
other than that we might we depends how
long it takes but we may come back and
uh deliver the decision verbally tonight
so we'll just discuss that in the closed
session with the uh with our solicitor
okay so thank you for your patience i
just beg beg your patience a bit longer
um and then we'll we'll come back to you
and uh
and relay to you what we've decided
thank you thank you